[music]
>> Brother Firdaus or brother Muhammad
Hisham.
Yes, brother Hisham.
So, we are going in an order. One
question from here and the other
question from there.
Yes, brother.
I have two questions. Um the first part
is based on this characteristics of a
dying and second was just because uh Dr.
Zakir Naik highlighted the point of uh
shaking hands.
So, my first part
is it permissible if we initiate Dawah
by having a facade
of a non-Muslim? This is so
Now, can you please repeat that word?
I repeat. Is it permissible if we
initiate Dawah
by having a facade of a non-Muslim so as
not to put him off?
>> [snorts]
>> A facade facade uh
an impression um
a covering. Should I say?
Covering that you pretend you pretend
to be a non-Muslim so as
not to turn him off?
That's my first question.
The second one on uh regarding uh since
he Dr. Zakir Naik highlighted on shaking
hands.
And also
I would request you to restrict to one
question and just as Zakir bhai said
that inshallah when he comes for the
other question answer session, you can
ask him that question about shaking
hands.
>> Inshallah. Inshallah.
If I have rightly understood your
question uh brother Hisham that to
initiate Dawah can a person pretend to
be a non-Muslim, right?
Not directly, but
having the impression. That's why it's a
facade.
Having the impression of being a
non-Muslim. You don't say that you're a
non-Muslim, you know. So, without the
cap, people have the impression that uh
he's neutral.
Brother has added one more point to it
that without a cap
do you mean to say that if a person does
not wear a cap, he becomes a non-Muslim
or he gives an impression of a
non-Muslim? He could be anything other
than a Muslim.
Brother
as far as the initiation of Dawah is
concerned
cap you mentioned is not the only label
of a Muslim.
There is beard.
Cap is
at the most mustahab.
But it is not far. Do you mean to say by
giving an impression of a non-Muslim,
you want to shave off your beard? This
is haram. How can you give the
impression of a non-Muslim by shaving
off your beard?
If you say, "No, I want to wear punk
style jeans hanging below my ankles so
that I can be with the punks and I can
do Dawah." Definitely, it's not allowed.
For a Muslim man to wear his trousers to
wear his pants below the ankles is
haram.
So, if you mean to say that to give an
impression
to the non-Muslim that I am a non-Muslim
and I start behaving and I start copying
them in some of their aspects which are
haram in Islam, this is definitely not
permissible.
There are many ways how you can initiate
Dawah. Dr. Zakir Naik just you know,
highlighted it. Inshallah, during the
course of the program, you will learn
many more ways how you can effectively
initiate Dawah by being inshallah proud
Muslim. By carrying your label with you.
By wearing a cap.
By sporting a beard. By wearing your
trousers above the ankle.
And during the course of time inshallah
during this Dawah training program,
inshallah more points will be added on
to it. Inshallah. Jazakallahu Khairan.
Do we have any more questions or we end
the session? Yes, brother Shafiq. This
will be the last question. Inshallah.
My question is
uh being a specialized Dahi and
being a normal Muslim from my
understanding being a normal Muslim
every Muslim should do Dawah.
So, is there any
uh different between
this criteria that you have listed? Is
it for normal Muslim every Muslim should
strive for these values or like only
those who
going to
call themselves
on a platform that they are Dahi or is
it does it apply
to layman Muslim as well? So, like
meaning that instead of
uh calling this criteria of a Dahi
is it right for me to say criteria of a
Muslim as well? Brother Shafiq has asked
a very good question that the
characteristics which I spoke about that
a Dahi should have, is it only
restricted to the Dahis or is it for all
the lay Muslims? A very good question.
Brother
by counting the characteristics of a
Dahi, we are actually inspiring every
Muslim to become a Dahi.
So, if you say that these
characteristics of a Dahi, that means
these characteristics are also for a
Muslim.
That every Muslim should do Dawah. Every
Muslim should be a Dahi.
So, by the characteristics of a Dahi, we
are telling the Muslim Ummah as a Muslim
what the Quran and what the Sunnah of
the messenger Sallallahu Alaihi Wasallam
said that if you do Dawah
you should base your Dawah on these firm
foundations, on these firm pillars.
Indirectly, we are giving a message to
the Muslims that all Muslims are
supposed to be Dahis and all the Dahis
who are also Muslims should have these
characteristics of a Dahi. Hope I've
answered your question. Jazakallahu
Khairan wa akhiru dawana wal
hamdulillahi rabbil alameen. Inshallah,
we'll move on to the next session which
is your turn to come on the stage and
give a three-minute prepared speech.
Inshallah. Jazakallahu Khairan wa akhiru
dawana wal hamdulillahi rabbil alameen.
Wassalamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
barakatuh.
Assalamu alaykum wa rahmatullahi wa
Inshallah, as mentioned earlier, we will
first have an introduction
of the newly joined participant that is
brother
and after that will be followed in
order.
We'll start from the left
going towards the right
from the first row then from the left
second row going towards the right
then the third row and the fourth row.
Each participant would have to give his
speech as was mentioned in the homework
that you have to prepare a three-minute
speech
of the topic of your choice in the way
you feel is the best.
So, inshallah first we'll have brother
Atiq.
He has about three minutes to introduce
himself.
And then later on we will go with the
prepared speech.
So, brothers my name is uh
Atiq Naik
and I'm 33 years old
and I'm born and brought up in Mumbai
and currently I'm living in the
Netherlands in The Hague. Uh it's like a
political city. I'm sure you're you're
aware of it. And I'm a intercultural
trainer.
So, I help uh European companies who are
doing businesses with India. I give them
training on and help them communicate
better with Indian businesses.
So, I usually give trainings to big
companies like Tesco, ABB
and uh Fabco mostly all over Europe.
So, this is what I do and uh I have
passion for fitness
and uh reading. I like reading a lot.
And uh
I think I'm uh
I'm very excited to be on this Dawah
program here because uh I found this is
an opportunity to learn about Islam and
convey the message of truth and to bring
people to Islam. And uh this was uh very
important thing for me
to come here.
And
uh so, I hope Allah guides me and helps
me in attaining my goal.
And
uh inshallah I plan to go and give Dawah
back in Europe because I I find people
like uh there are a lot of Muslims who
are barely hanging on to Islam by a
piece of thread. And you know, so I just
want to bring them all on the right path
and convey the message of truth.
So,
yeah, that's it about me. That's all,
brothers.
Thank you, Jazakallah.
Can we have the first participant?
Brother Sabu.
Audhu billahi samee'il aleem.
Minash shaytanir rajeem. Bismillahir
rahmanir raheem.
Rabbishrahli sadri wa yassirli amri.
Wahlul uqdatan min lisani yafqahu qawli.
Allahumma la ilmalana illa ma allamtana
innaka antal aleemul hakeem.
Was salatu was salamu ala ashrafil
ambiya'i wal mursaleen.
Sayyidina Muhammad Sallallahu alaihi wa
alihi wa ashabihi ajma'een wa ba'd.
>> It's a great opportunity for me to stand
here
to make a speech or a topic
on
what is called brotherhood in Islam.
I will start by quoting a verses from
the Holy Quran.
That's chapter 49
verse
13.
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
said, "Ya ayyuha nas
inna khalaqnakum min zakarin wa untha
wa ja'alnakum shu'uban wa qaba'ila li
ta'arafu.
Inna akramakum 'indallahi atqakum.
Innallaha 'alimun khabir."
Allah said,
is a general call
to all mankind.
As we know,
sometimes Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala in
Quran call the entire mankind.
In other ways, he only calls the
believers.
In some verses, you will have that Allah
said,
"Ya ayyuhallazina amanu."
While in the other hand, you will also
hear
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala call the
kafirun. So, when Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala said, "Ya ayyuha nas,"
this is a general call
to all mankind.
Be it you are a Muslim, be it Christian,
be it Jews, whatever, whoever, whatever
group or sect
or religion you belongs to, is a general
call by Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala.
"Inna khalaqnakum min zakarin wa untha."
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala want to
clarify something, to tell us that we
are created for a from a single male and
female.
That's
Prophet Adam alayhis salam
and Hawa.
We are created the purpose of our
creation.
And after our creation, Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala in his mercy
said, "Wa ja'alnakum shu'uban wa
qaba'ila li ta'arafu."
Despite the fact that we are created
from a single male and female,
but Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
wants to also divide us into nations and
tribes.
Make us into different nations and
tribes. As we are all sitting here, we
have about 11 countries here.
Some of us are
black, as I am. Some are white, some are
with different
tribe from different tribes.
But what is there? Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala What is the hikmah? What is the
partition? Why we are partitioned into
nations and tribes?
Is that
"Min zakarin wa untha wa ja'alnakum
shu'uban li ta'arafu at-ta'arif."
Allah partition us into groups, into
nations, into tribes so that at-ta'aruf,
so that we can know each other. You can
know who I am, I can know who you are.
You can know my tribe, I can know your
tribe.
So, that is the hikmah of dividing up
into nations and tribes by Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala.
But the best out of it is that
"Inna akramakum 'indallahi atqakum." The
best The most honored among you
is the right person. Assalamualaikum wa
rahmatullahi wa barakatuh. Wa alaykum
assalam wa rahmatullahi wa barakatuh.
>> [music]
[music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.
>> [music]
>> Allah.
Allah.